When it comes to the fantastic, weird and
wonderful world of comic book characters,
it's easy to think that they're all entirely
fictitious and created solely from the imaginations
of talented writers.
In some cases, that may well be true, but
there are also some very real inspirations
behind a lot of them.
Obviously there's nobody in the real world
who can lift a building, travel around the
world in ten seconds or take a bullet to the
eye without suffering a horrific injury, but
the personalities, appearances and lifestyles
of many comic book characters are very much
based on people who have really existed.
This notion applies to superheroes, supervillains
and indeed supporting characters and we’ll
look at some examples of all those in this
video.
Here are 10 comic book characters you didn't
know are based on real people.
Iron Man
Marvel legends Stan Lee, Jack Kirby, Larry
Lieber and Don Heck created Iron Man with
a very famous business tycoon in mind.
That man was Howard Hughes and Lee described
him as being "an inventor, an adventurer,
a multi-billionaire, a ladies' man and finally
a nutcase" - doesn't all of that sound exactly
like Tony Stark?
Hughes was incredibly rich and lived the kind
of eccentric life that most people could only
dream of - and that's certainly reflected
in Stark's lifestyle too.
He also suffered from a crippling obsessive-compulsive
disorder - something that is touched upon
in a less devastating way in some of Tony
Stark's behaviour, such as his refusal to
be handed things.
Batman
Artist Bob Kane and writer Bill Finger came
up with the idea for Batman AKA Bruce Wayne,
but their inspiration for the kind of character
he would be came from two very well-known
historical figures.
Not only did they take Batman's real name
from the men in question, they also based
the kind of hero he would be on them.
The first was Robert the Bruce - a famous
warrior who led Scotland against England during
the Scottish War of Independence.
And the second was Mad Anthony Wayne - a war
general during the American Revolution who
became famous for winning battles against
opposition with bigger numbers, just like
Batman fights a one-man war against crime
in Gotham City.
Wonder Woman
The incredibly powerful Amazon princess known
as Wonder Woman was based on two extremely
strong and formidable women from the real
world.
Wonder Woman's creator, William Moulton Marston
- the same man who invented the lie detector
- took inspiration from two of the most important
women in his life to create the superheroine.
The first was his wife, Elizabeth, and the
second was his research assistant, Olive Byrne.
Elizabeth inspired William to create someone
who triumphed over evil with love, while Olive
wore Arabic "protection bracelets" that inspired
the creation of Wonder Woman's Bracelets of
Submission.
Constantine
Created in a joint effort by Alan Moore, Stephen
R. Bissette and John Totleben, anti-hero and
supernatural expert John Constantine was actually
inspired by world famous musician and former
front-man of The Police, Sting.
In this case, the inspiration came in the
form of the character's likeness.
Early illustrations of Constantine heavily
resembled Sting both facially and in terms
of the character's clothing, and there was
even a nod to this fact in one of the character's
first appearances on-panel, when Constantine
appeared on a boat with the words The Honourable
Gordon Sumner - Sting's real name - written
on the bow.
Bucky Barnes
These days, pretty much everyone knows Bucky
Barnes as the best friend of Steve Rogers
AKA Captain America.
The pair went to school together and are the
same age - but that wasn't always the case.
Bucky was introduced in the comic books as
a schoolboy companion to the grown-up Captain
America and was actually based on a real-life
schoolkid.
Bucky was created by Joe Simon and Jack Kirby
and Simon revealed that he was named after
Bucky Pierson, a star player on his high school
basketball team.
The Flash
There have, of course, been several characters
who have gone by the name The Flash throughout
DC Comics' history - Jay Garrick, Wally West
and Bart Allen, for example - but the second
super-fast hero to go by the name was Barry
Allen.
Barry Allen was named after two different
iconic American talk show hosts from different
media platforms.
Writer Robert Kanigher and artist Carmine
Infantino came up with his name by combining
those of radio host Barry Gray and Steve Allen,
the first host of television's The Tonight
Show.
J. Jonah Jameson
There's simply no way we could create a list
like this without mentioning J. Jonah Jameson
– and there’s an extremely good reason
for that.
It's because Jameson was based on none other
than real-life Marvel legend Stan Lee!
Created By Steve Ditko and Lee himself, Jameson
is an exaggerated, much angrier version of
the latter.
The Spider-Man-hater and editor-in-chief of
the Daily Bugle resembles Lee in terms of
his appearance and has an amplified version
of the former Marvel president's already huge
personality.
Professor X
Created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby, the personality
of the X-Men's wise mutant mentor Professor
Charles Xavier - also known as Professor X
- is quite famously inspired by Martin Luther
King Jr. (with Magneto - his more militant
and often more evil counterpart - being inspired
by Malcolm X, incidentally).
But his appearance was influenced by a real-life
individual too.
That man was Russian actor and The King and
I star Yul Brynner, whose bald head and extremely
prominent eye-brows were quite obviously mirrored
by those of the telepathic superhero.
Superman
No list of comic book characters is ever complete
without the most iconic of them all - Superman.
Pretty much every aspect of the Man of Steel
was inspired by real-life people.
Superman was created by Jerry Siegel and Joe
Shuster, both of whom were fond of swashbuckling
movies like Robin Hood and The Mark of Zorro
- so they modeled Superman's physique and
poses on the star of those movies, Douglas
Fairbanks Sr.
The look of his alter-ego, Clark Kent, was
based on the appearance of both Shuster and
silent actor Harold Lloyd, while his name
was a combination of actors Clark Gable and
Kent Taylor's.
The Joker
Don't worry, nobody in existence has ever
been quite crazy enough to have their personality
inspire the creation of The Joker, but there
was a real-life actor whose iconic silent
movie character formed the basis of Batman's
most formidable foe.
In The Man Who Laughs, Conrad Veidt played
a man whose facial disfigurement meant it
looked like he was creepily grinning all the
time.
The Joker's creator, Bob Kane, came up with
the idea to apply that concept to his character
- although the initial idea for The Joker
character actually came from a 17-year-old
boy he knew called Jerry Robinson.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 comic book
characters you didn't know are based on real
people.
Did you know about all of these?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!